where's my hat mr. white where's my hat
yo we're ready to film level this'll be
crazy
hi I'm Ryan Wright and though this would
be crazy welcome to the real rejects
where we watch fun things and try to
make you laugh and then we review them
it's like a hangout show yeah it's a ton
of fun it's a ton of fun it's like we're
friends you know cuz because then we get
comments ooh yeah it's like it's
redacted he's interactive it's a
connection so listen guys I'm a little
sick and well sometimes there's only one
thing though really how about I'm a
little bit you know ha didn't actually
say anything you all made a safe zone
much I know but that's what counts
ok so I thought what better day then to
watch racist Mario I've heard your
please I kept on going back to hutch to
watch the Luigi death stare at all you
guys were like watch races to Mario I'm
like what the hell is this what's your
impression of the subscribers watch
licensed Mario oh I read it was like oh
what a horrible right now you want us to
watch your races anyway let's watch this
video
[Music]
yeah jump
[Music]
I will muse no trouble go back into your
the cat's done what's up
knuckles must be Mario he just
characters
[Music]
[Music]
what is he some kind of racist you're
not depend of your feet and oh you're
strangers
[Music]
[Music]
23d jumping of
[Music]
[Music]
wait Mario think of our history so you
like it to go fast
alright I got it now it's mine and I can
force it to do whatever I want brothers
Marlo oh it's great oz no PlayStation
characters never learn
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm kind of not I'm watching this what
do you mean I was there to be more as
awful as it was it was really
entertaining yeah that's pretty funny I
mean I don't know why but like racist
I think racism is so silly first off
because I don't have someone has met
enough people to go
I hate millions of other people like you
just doesn't make sense but for some
reason racist jokes are funny as hell to
me well this is a very very different
time oh yeah domestic violence and
pedophilia
yeah Ash Ketchum was your head of fun
here we're talking about I wasn't
listening racing race racing oh you're
talking about racing Oh racist was that
the whole point of the video because he
was pretty racist the race yeah yeah I
mean he was racist toward other
characters in in racing so yeah what are
you getting at it's funny got it I got
it
dad I was violent over the top it's
exactly what you want from a fun
animated YouTube video man it was done
very very well
yeah that's pretty scary like yeah if
some like people were in the room like
what if this person said this you know
what if Donkey Kong had this happen to
him really it seemed like people were
just having a fun time creating this
people think really yeah I can imagine
you being involved in something like
this you would come up with some pretty
good one yeah I probably would yeah you
would I probably would yeah first off
peach I would again her two black guys
okay start off with that Luigi I would I
would have made Luigi they paralyzed
from the waist down I would have made
Yoshi a a former black slave I think all
those combinations are funny that
doesn't even make sense it makes perfect
sense that's not it's not funny and
doesn't even make sense that it's no
wait hold on ELISA it's the funniest
thing I've said it a long time it's
[ __ ] hilarious
that's what it is it's just us two in
the room if a tree falls in the woods
does anyone hear it does it make a noise
that was my question I [ __ ] up
question what about them what about them
trees if they fall in the woods and are
recorded
you can still see they fell these guys
they know they know what you said they
know what you did dude I literally don't
know what's happening right let's do
some shoutouts
but before that you can subscribe to the
real rejects ELISA has a channel where
she's like literally she's crazy
ELISA be crazy subscribe to that crazy
ass [ __ ]
let's shout some mofos out do it let's
do with to it don't stop you to you
that's real Oh God outdated hey man can
i get a shout out the d the big smiley
face and a heart sign dude yeah oh god
outdated I don't know what your name
means man but it's kind of clever
because it makes me think like God is
outdated and it's like whoa what if he
is isn't he supposed to be a beginning
and end right you just offended a bunch
of people I don't know fed a bunch of
people I seriously contemplated
something okay no he's the one offending
people I was just reading isn't it
enough what if it's in terms of like VHS
is like those are outdated they're like
oh god why do you still have that that's
outdated well yet it a lot more words
then what are actually there right now
I'm just saying you were contemplating I
was contemplating do totally do and we
will both contemplate and you know the
other to be less offensive it's um it's
impossible I could come up with a bunch
of racist jokes hi Russell
great video guys keep up the good work
question what is your favorite movie
Ryan also can i have a shout out for
starters my favorite movie tends to
fluctuate
sometimes it's the matrix because of its
story character development kind of wait
ya know those characters elemina
sometimes Terminator 2 sometimes it's
Drive it's probably
that's pretty much it yeah guy Russell
that's a mile of Ryan Gosling I really
do like if I met him I probably cry
really yeah like a little [ __ ] gorgeous
person that he is TV I know you've seen
him before
he's like sunshine radiating you know
he's just so cool he has the most
relaxed shoulders it's like he has no
attention about right have you seen him
he's just so relaxed on camera it's
amazing like my shoulders are a little
tense right now his are just like
perfectly like it's like NES great
posture
watch my Ryan Gosling Rasim it's awesome
Shrek m8 can you please shout out my
Twitter at Jar Jar boom dude I'm gonna
help promote your ass right now Jar Jar
boom you guys have a Twitter I want you
to follow at Jar Jar boom Shrek MA this
is YouTube baby now I don't really
remember if him and I have ever had a
conversation but you better follow him
on Twitter you understand me
hey hey hey p'mote but looking at his
name it's Shrek m8 Shrek mate like
checkmate with Shrek how does that make
a difference
am I in my thing because you probably
read it wrong Shrek me I mean I did read
it wrong but the actual context of what
we were talking about you know what I'm
talking I'm not being helpful apparently
no you're really not
what is that talking you keep talking
this is the last shower no Alyssa you be
angry